so we now know that there are two ways
that a company can raise capital it can
do it by
borrowing money which is debt
or by selling shares of itself or
essentially allowing other people to
become partial owners of it and that is
equity
and these directly translate into
securities that you're probably familiar
with but maybe you didn't have a
more exact idea of what they are you
know what equity securities are just you
know what is the security a security is
essentially something that can be bought
and sold that has some type of
claim on something or some type of
economic value so a security in the
equity world is a stock
and a security in the debt world is a
bond let me explain that so let me just
draw the balance sheet for a
for the fictional company
it was pointed out to me that socks.com
actually is not a fictional company that
someone is indeed selling socks online
so
which by by the way i think is a great
idea so let's see let's see either they
my
my assets right here these are the
assets of the company but that's not
what we're worried about right now
assets and let me draw the equity
of the company
and this is maybe shares that they sold
and
so let's say that they have
i don't know that there are 10 million
shares
10 million shares
and then we have the debt
the debt of the company or the
liabilities there are other liabilities
other than debt per se but that's all
we'll worry about right now this is the
debt i'll do it in brown
we have the debt
the debt and maybe the assets let me
just think of a good round number
the assets are 10 million dollars in
assets
and let's say our
is six million dollars and then what's
i
debt
left over for the equity right and the
way you have to view is okay if i have
ten million dollars and i owe people six
million dollars what's left for the
owners of the company well the owners of
the company will have four million
dollars left four million dollars left
and it'll be split amongst the owners of
of the company and there's 10 million
individual shares so if if every every
person who has one of those stock
certificates will own one ten millionth
of this four million dollars or
essentially was at 40 cents a share or
something so anyway this is and i think
you're familiar with this already this
is essentially
stock
right when we say 10 million shares
that's 10 million shares of stock i
could just draw a bunch of i could draw
10 million stock certificates
and you know it's i guess we'll you know
whatever the ticker symbol is
and there could be 10 million of those
now debt is interesting there's a lot of
ways you can raise that actually there's
a lot of ways you could raise equity it
actually doesn't have to be with selling
well for the most part you are selling
stock um you could maybe think of some
other way and we'll talk about other
forms of equity preferred stock and all
of that but in the simplest level you're
really always selling stock that's a
little different that could be just in
the form of a bank loan so you know this
could be a
a bank loan where you literally go to
the bank and say hey i need six million
dollars and they say okay here you go
and we'll give it to you for this
interest and you have to pay back the
money above and beyond the interest over
this time schedule so you know not too
different than maybe a mortgage or they
might say okay you pay the interest for
five years at the end of the five years
you have to pay
you also have to pay the principal
amount so you have to pay the whole six
million dollars so you maybe have to
come up with a new loan or something
like that so that would just be a bank
loan there's other things that are
revolving lines of credit which is kind
of like a a a company's uh like i guess
a company's credit card to some degree
that it doesn't have to use it but if it
does that's kind of debt the company
takes on
but kind of the the one that people
always talk about i guess in the same
phrase is bonds so bonds are essentially
you you are borrowing from the public
markets again you're borrowing from a
bunch of people so what you do is you
have these six million
let's say the six million dollars and it
could be divided into
what we let me think of a good now you
could you could divide this into six
thousand bond certificates
right so this could be this could be six
thousand
bond certificates let's see in six
million divided six thousand right
that's a thousand right so it could be
six thousand times
one thousand dollar
bond
certificates bond certificates
certificates and
let's visualize what a bond certificate
could look like
so that could be a bond certificate and
it's face value and sometimes they'll
call it the par value or the stated
value it'll say you know let's call it
bond from company
xyz
and it is its face value is a thousand
dollars
so it's essentially this is an iou from
company xyz if i were to hold one of
these
if i had one of these sitting on my desk
right now that tells me that company xyz
is going to pay me one thousand dollars
at some future date right and that
future date is at maturity so it's going
to pay
one thousand dollars
one thousand dollars
at maturity
maturity and you say oh well sal you
know that's that's all good but what
about the interest in between and
there's two ways to think about this
maybe
maybe they're going to pay me a thousand
dollars in the future but i only have to
give them 500 right so if you think
about it there's automatically interest
accruing in that right if i gave them
500
and then five years later they pay me a
thousand dollars they're essentially
paying interest right they're paying me
more back than i gave to them and we'll
in future videos we'll actually do the
math of how to figure out that type of
interest and in that situation where
they're not kind of paying me interest
as they go this would kind this would be
viewed as a zero coupon bond and i know
i'm throwing out a lot of terminology
but it'll all make sense to you in a
second so zero coupon essentially means
they're not paying interest
until they pay off the whole loan and
then they might kind of the the interest
will be implicit in the whole value of
the amount
and i kind of jumped the gun a little
bit but coupon is essentially a regular
payment on the bond that the company
makes in this case xyz will make that is
essentially you can almost view it as a
kind of interest but if you really had
to figure out the interest that you're
getting on the bond you would actually
have to figure out i'll do a whole i'll
do maybe a whole playlist on bond
mathematics you would have to figure out
you it's based on the coupon what you
gave them and then what they're going to
pay you and when they're going to do it
so it's a little bit more complicated
than just saying oh look at that they're
giving a a six percent coupon which is
meant essentially means you know twice a
year they're going to give me three
percent of the value of my bond
so just a big picture i mean both of
these things are traded
both of you know this is a stock it's
traded on exchange and you're probably
familiar that if you go to yahoo finance
you get you type in the ticker symbol
and you get the price for that day
bonds are also traded unfortunately it's
not as easy to get a quote on a bond
usually you have to have a bloomberg
terminal of some type yet you can't get
it on yahoo finance and i think that's
by design by bond traders because they
probably don't like the the transparency
there but it is just like just like a
stock it is a security it is traded
there is a price but there is a there's
a very fundamental difference in what
kind of the holder of the bond is doing
in a bond you essentially if i have if
i'm holding a 1 000 bond that means that
i've lent some amount of money to the
company and it'll be in this part of it
and as long as the company doesn't go
bankrupt they'll pay me some interest
and pay me my money back when i own a
stock in the company right i own a share
of the equity as opposed to a share of
the debt which was the case with the
bond when i own a share of the equity
the company's not paying promising to
pay back anything it's just saying look
you are a part owner of this company and
anything that any of the owners get
you'll get so if this company becomes
worth a lot if we start dividending out
things to the shareholders then you'll
get that if the company gets sold by
someone and pays x dollars per share for
it you'll get that money and if the
company goes bankrupt you'll also go
bankrupt
and that actually leads to an
interesting question if the company goes
bankrupt and let's say actually let's
let's let's do the example right now
let's say the company goes bankrupt
right and i'll do a more a more more
in-depth example of this the question is
let's say the company goes bankrupt and
people decide that it's not operational
anymore that it just can't do business
because there's actually two types of
bankruptcy there's one where you say oh
the cup the business is good and it just
it just can't pay off its debts so we
have to somehow restructure this side of
it and then the other type of bankruptcy
is liquidation where they say you know
what this business doesn't even make
sense to operate anymore let's just sell
off all of the assets so the question
i'll leave you with in this video is
what happens in situation where you
enter bankruptcy people tend to want to
liquidate the assets and let's say when
you liquidate the assets there's only
eight million dollars of assets
so the question is who do you think is
going to eat that two million dollars is
it going to be the debt holders or the
stockholders who is going to lose their
money first or you can almost say who is
more senior when it comes to actually
getting their money back and i'll leave
leave you with that maybe to the next
video or a future video that i'll do on
bankruptcy see you in the next video